the man at the very top may have been
removed but issues for Rochdale Borough
wide housing very much remain mold damp
and despair even two years on from the
death of a Wabi Shack
in every room of his family's flat the
boy was exposed to these dangerous
conditions despite repeated calls for
help nothing was done it means tenants
like awayzo are scared about what may
happen to them he lives in the flat
below with young and old seeing what
happened to the poor child it's not safe
to be letting this happening so
frequently like this and the ventilators
too old or breathing it in you see so
and my mother she doesn't have the best
health over the last week we visited six
homes on this estate with severe mold
and today Rochdale borawide housing told
us they've received 106 complaints of
mold within the last 12 months across
their 12 000 properties but one former
employee claims there are hundreds more
than that they have been putting profit
before people Eleanor not her real name
resigned from rbh a year ago she like
other former employees claims the
working culture was toxic and it impacts
customers in desperate need
tenants are basically being passed from
Pillar To Post and not getting the
answers they wanted I've been in
meetings where it has all been about
cost cutting how much can we save do you
reckon others could die at the hands of
rbh's properties if if there isn't
drastic change absolutely if it's
happened once it can happen again
it's why the housing secretary stepped
in and put rbh on a period of notice but
he now feels the blame goes beyond the
chief executive the board still felt it
was appropriate to keep the chief
executive in place and that seemed to me
you know you you shouldn't blame just
one individual But ultimately the chief
executive and the board should carry the
can in a statement the Housing
Association told us we provide a full
response to initial complaints on
average within five days and we are an
employee and tenant owned Mutual
organization with a strong set of values
at our core a cold and wet winter is
upon many across Rochdale and a lot of
these homes need desperate attention
many hoped awab's death would be a
defining moment instead it's only
Unearthed claims of a deeper issue in
saman Rashid Sky News Rochdale